[Música]
Hola ministros
[Aplausos]
en medio de abucheos contra la primera
ministra del gobierno francés activó el
artículo 49.3 que le permite aprobar la
reforma de las pensiones sin someterla
al voto de la asamblea nacional la
decisión ha desatado la indignación ante
oposición que ahora puede presentar una
moción de censura y de los sindicatos
que ya protestan en las calles Tenemos
reporte desde París
Estados Unidos publicó las imágenes del
supuesto derribo de uno de sus drones
militares en el mar Negro tras chocar
con un caza ruso según la caja según la
Casa Blanca el incidente
mostró la agresividad de Moscú y el
kremlin insistió en que el episodio
muestra la intervención de Washington en
Ucrania
en Irán este jueves se cumplen seis
meses desde que maxa mini murió bajo
custodia de la policía de la moral la
muerte de la joven kurda desató
revueltas masivas en contra del gobierno
fundamentalista de Teherán que han
marcado un antes y un después en la
sociedad iraní Tenemos reporte
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
más deu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles abrimos de nuevo esta
edición informativa en Francia porque
hoy ha sido un día de convulsión
política el gobierno ha activado el
artículo 49.3 de la Constitución para
forzar la aprobación de la polémica
reforma de las pensiones la activación
del 49.3 qué implica que El Ejecutivo
impide el debate y la votación sobre el
texto en la asamblea nacional por lo
tanto la única manera que tiene ahora la
oposición de rechazar la propuesta es
con una moción de censura contra el
gobierno el uso del 49.3 ha aumentado
los niveles de indignación entre
sindicatos y oposición recordemos que la
mayoría de franceses se opone al texto y
que los sindicatos han logrado
movilizaciones masivas en las calles del
país sin embargo el presidente Manuel
macron ha declinado hasta ahora reunirse
con los líderes sindicales y ha usado
este artículo el 49.3 precisamente ante
la posibilidad de que la asamblea
nacional rechazara el texto y a esta
hora cientos de personas han protestado
o protestan todavía en distintos puntos
del país contra la decisión del gobierno
nuestro periodista Luis Miguel Cabrera
nos manda el siguiente reporte desde la
capital francesa
la cólera tras la aprobación a la fuerza
de la Reforma de pensiones del
presidente Emmanuel macron salió Desde
la asamblea nacional hasta sus
inmediaciones donde varios cientos de
personas se congregaron al llamado de la
organización intersindical hace unos
minutos las personas que estaban
congregadas aquí fueron evacuadas hacia
el otro lado de la Plaza de la Concordia
donde me encuentro cerca del hotel por
un dispositivo de seguridad de los
cuerpos republicanos de seguridad que
están desplegados en este momento aquí
en la Plaza de la Concordia como podemos
ver aquí a mi derecha están bloqueando
también el acceso en la avenida de los
campos elíseos todo esto ocurre A pocas
horas de la aprobación de la Reforma de
pensiones y tras el llamado de esa
organización intersindical a una novena
jornada de manifestaciones en todo el
país a partir del jueves próximo O el
jueves próximo luego de este fin de
semana donde se realizarán también
manifestaciones en varias partes del
país Así que la batalla por la reforma
de pensiones en el legislativo acaba de
concluir pero aquí en la calle continúa
y vamos con otra de las noticias del
momento Y es que Estados Unidos y Rusia
siguen manteniendo versiones encontradas
sobre lo ocurrido con el dron de
Washington derribado sobre el mar Negro
tras chocar contra un caza ruso el
kremlin niega la versión estadounidense
y afirma que la colisión se debió a un
giro brusco del aparato de Estados
Unidos además
Moscú señala que el episodio Revela la
intervención de Washington en Ucrania
más detalles en el siguiente informe
estas imágenes difundidas por Estados
Unidos muestran como su dron cae en el
mar Negro tras Aparentemente chocar con
una aeronave rusa en esta última
escalada de tensiones entre Estados
Unidos y Rusia a pesar de las imágenes
mientras que Washington sostiene que el
avión no tripulado fue alcanzado por un
caza ruso
Moscú sigue negando que se produjera
contacto alguno algo por lo que el
miércoles los ministros de defensa de
ambos países iniciaron conversaciones
telefónicas
No hablaré En nombre del ministro choygu
ni entrar en los detalles de nuestra
discusión me limitaré a reiterar que
Estados Unidos volará y operará allí
donde lo permita el derecho
internacional ahora bien nos tomamos muy
en serio cualquier posibilidad de
escalada y por eso creo que es
importante mantener abiertas las líneas
de comunicación
es el primer incidente directo entre
Rusia y Estados Unidos desde que comenzó
la guerra en Ucrania según Washington es
una prueba de comportamiento agresivo y
arriesgado del kremlin en aguas
internacionales y según Moscú el dron
demuestra la implicación de Estados
Unidos en la guerra y advierte que
podría provocar a más tensiones
se constató que los drones estratégicos
letales estadounidenses en la costa de
crimea tuvieron una actitud provocativa
y crearon condiciones para una escalada
de la situación en la zona del mar Negro
tras este incidente ambas naciones
deciden querer evitar una escalada pero
con las relaciones en un punto crítico
podrían producirse consecuencias
diplomáticas y entre tanto durante un
encuentro con la élite empresarial rusa
el presidente Vladimir Putin afirmó que
su país está enfrentando una guerra
contra las sanciones internacionales y
urgió a los empresarios crear un nuevo
modelo de economía rusa desde Moscú
Xavier colás con los detalles
el presidente Putin se ha reunido por
primera vez desde el inicio de la
invasión con la élite empresarial rusa
muchos de esos empresarios están bajo
sanciones por culpa de lo que pudin
llamar la operación militar especial su
guerra en Ucrania algunos de esos
empresarios le han dicho que tienen
dificultades para acceder a las
tecnologías occidentales con esta nueva
situación de sanciones Putin les ha
pedido que inviertan en su país para que
así Rusia pueda capear lo que pudieran
ha calificado de guerra de sanciones
occidental el presidente Putin les ha
pedido que pongan su Patriotismo por
delante de las ganancias y ha elogiado
la resiliencia de Rusia Es verdad que la
contracción del 2% de la economía del
país ha resultado un pronóstico mucho
mejor que los malos augurios que se
tenían sobre la economía rusa Aunque la
mayoría de expertos creen que va a pasar
mucho tiempo hasta que Rusia pueda
volver a obtener el crecimiento de
tiempo
y en otras noticias en Irán se cumplen
hoy 6 meses Desde que la joven maxa
amini murió bajo custodia de la policía
de la moral que recordemos la detuvo por
llevar mal puesto el velo la muerte de
la joven kurdo iraní desató una ola de
protestas masivas Bajo lemas como mujer
vida y libertad o muerte al dictador
además las movilizaciones contra el
gobierno fundamentalista de la república
islámica se acentuaron por la mortal
represión ejercida por la fuerza pública
desde Teherán nuestra corresponsal
Catalina Gómez Ángel nos cuenta cómo
está el país seis meses después de un
estallido social que supuso un antes y
un después para la sociedad
iranísimo país que lo era hace seis
meses por múltiples motivos uno de ellos
por este velo que se han dejado caer
muchísimas mujeres e incluso muchas de
ellas se han quitado después de que Max
examiní esa joven de 22 años muriera
después pudo haber sido capturada por la
policía de la moral un huracaya del
centro de tehterando muy lejos de aquí
por no llevar supuestamente bien su velo
a pesar de que las autoridades han
negado atropellos en contra de esta
jóvenes que cuando estaba capturada
sufrió una muerte cerebral para muchas
miles y miles de jóvenes que han sido
capturadas durante estos años por esta
policía y han sido testigos de los
atropellos para ellas Esto no es un
argumento Y acusan a esta policía de
haber sido la causante de la muerte de
esta joven y por eso de allí esas
protestas que sacudieron al país
inmediatamente después de su
fallecimiento y también porque la
mayoría de las mujeres y la mayoría de
ellas muy jóvenes también Hicieron estas
protestas quitándose el velo lo que ha
cambiado no solamente al país sino
también a la actitud del régimen de la
república islámica que reprimió con
enorme violencia esas protestas más de
500 personas fallecieron durante las
primeras especialmente así lo ha
monitoreado organizaciones de Derechos
Humanos que siguen la situación en Irán
miles y miles de personas muchos de
ellos jóvenes estudiantes terminaron en
prisión pero respecto al velo lo que ha
hecho la República islámica es tratar de
mirar hacia otro lado al menos cuando
las personas las personas no cantan
eslóganes políticos en la calle han
tratado de reponerlo
de otras veces restaurantes o
monitoreando en las calles con cámaras
Pero esto es bastante difícil Esto hace
que este haya sido uno de los grandes
cambios en este año persa que terminará
el 21 de Marzo muchos también saben que
en gran parte de la población o un gran
sector se alejó del régimen muchas de
ellas ya lo estaba pero la manera como
reprimieron estas protestas hizo que
mayor parte de la población estuviera
descontenta con sus autoridades
y en Grecia empleados de trenes barcos
aviones y del transporte público en
general paralizaron sus operaciones en
una protesta masiva en contra de la
precariedad del sector de los
transportes cerca de 40.000 personas
participaron en una movilización que
sigue con las demandas de mejores
condiciones e inversiones En donde en
los servicios demandas desatadas a raíz
del choque de trenes en que murieron 57
personas el 28 de febrero Juan Pablo
tiene más detalles
por aire tierra o mar el transporte se
detiene en Grecia conductores de trenes
barcos aviones y del transporte público
de las principales ciudades apagaron el
motor de sus vehículos para protestar
por el accidente más grave del país en
el que murieron 57 personas el pasado 28
de febrero el accidente se dio entre un
tren de 350 pasajeros y un tren de carga
ambos colisionaron de frente en la
región central griega de tempi cerca de
larisa
tras el suceso los trabajadores han
denunciado la falta de inversión pública
y la deficiencia de las medidas de
seguridad en el ferrocarril griego
creo que las medidas deberían haberse
tomado hace mucho tiempo y no deberían
estar esperando a que sucediera un
accidente para tomarlas de igual manera
sean cual sean las medidas no aplacarán
el dolor del pueblo
en la huelga de hoy que se espera sea de
24 horas y que llegó hasta inmediaciones
del parlamento fue convocada por los
sindicatos más grandes del sector
público y privado la gente está muy
enojada pero tampoco saben qué hacer no
podemos cambiar repentinamente a todos
los políticos Entonces qué podemos hacer
la gente no sabe la gente está muy
triste ni siquiera sabemos Qué hacer en
las próximas elecciones no sabemos qué
hacer una vez frente al parlamento las
manifestaciones estallaron en
enfrentamientos con la policía con gases
lacrimógenos piedras y bombas Molotov
la semana pasada miles de personas
salieron a las calles en lo que fue una
de las mayores protestas contra el
gobierno que asumió en 2019 el Primer
Ministro críacos mitsutakis cuyo mandato
finaliza en julio Se disculpó
públicamente por el accidente y prometió
modernizar las líneas e impulsar la mano
de obra en el sector ferroviario
y en noticias económicas El Banco
Central europeo mantiene lo previsto
subiendo 50 puntos básicos los tipos de
interés para tratar de aliviar la
inflación las principales bolsas del
continente respondieron positivamente al
anuncio Y cerraron al alza tras haber
tenido resultados negativos el día de
ayer por la caída de las acciones del
banco suizo Credit suiz nos amplía
nuestra corresponsal en Bruselas Esther
Herrera
pese a las turbulencias del sector
financiero de los últimos días del Banco
Central europeo ha decidido mantener su
hoja de ruta y ha aumentado en 50 puntos
básicos los tipos de interés llegando
así al 3,5% la decisión se toman después
de la caída del banco de silicon Valley
de Estados Unidos y la crisis de las
últimas horas de El credits en lugar de
moderar los tipos tal y como preveían
algunos analistas ha decidido mantener
esta hoja de ruta de seguir adelante
pero con un mensaje claro de que en caso
de que sea necesario inyectará liquidez
para evitar cualquier tipo de problema
en una hipotética crisis financiera en
cualquier caso El Banco Central europeo
argumentado su decisión porque tampoco
tenía más margen la inflación sigue
disparada en toda la eurozona con más de
un 8% Especialmente encarecidos los
alimentos y muy lejos del objetivo
ciento que es el que tiene el euro banco
en mente y por lo tanto era necesario
actuar asegurado su presidenta Christine
lagart aún así debido a las
incertidumbres el euro banco de momento
no desvela que va a hacer en el futuro
si va a seguir esta senda de seguir
subiendo los tipos porque necesita
decidir exactamente qué es lo que va a
hacer con unos datos financieros y
económicos en la mano de todas formas El
Banco Central europeo ha querido Llamar
a la calma de que ahora mismo no se está
en las mismas situación que la crisis
financiera de 2008 que la banca es
solvente que es fuerte y descarta de
momento cualquier crisis de liquidez
las autoridades chinas aseguran que
Estados Unidos no ha aportado pruebas de
que tiktok suponga una amenaza a la
seguridad nacional estadounidense y
piden a Washington que deje de propagar
información falsa el comentario responde
a la amenaza de la Administración biden
hacia la compañía propietaria de tiktok
bidence con sede en Beijing el
departamento del tesoro estadounidense
comunicó a la empresa china que si no se
vende tiktok Estados Unidos plantea
prohibir el uso de la aplicación por
temor a que los datos de los 100
millones de usuarios estadounidenses
lleguen a manos del Estado chino
llegamos así al fin de esta emisión pero
sigan con nosotros y más información
[Música]